- [Instructor] Let's give ourselves
a little bit more food for thought
on this labor versus capital question.
So like we've mentioned many times,
in order to produce anything,
you need a little bit of both
or you maybe need a lot of both.
You need labor,
and,
and you need capital.
The question is as you
produce that output,
as you produce that output,
or I guess you could say
as you produce this
aggregate, this product,
how do you decide how
much of it goes to labor
and how much of it goes to capital?
Well, one way to think about it
is which resource has more leverage?
If you go back to the Gilded Age,
Gilded Age,
really the peak of Industrial Revolution,
the people who had most of the leverage
were the owners of capital,
the growth industries,
as we've said before.
These were railroads,
these were manufacturing plants,
these were people
exploring and finding oil.
And so capital had all the leverage.
That the labor, most of
the labor that was involved
was fairly unskilled and was
viewed by the owners of capital
as something of a commodity.
And so more and more of
the outcome or the income
could go to the capital.
Now, Piketty
at least hints that, hey,
maybe we're going to a second Gilded Age
because returns on capital are going
to be larger than growth,
and more and more wealth is
going to be going to that.
But to do a thought
experiment, once again,
this'll give you food for thought,
and you come up with your own conclusions.
Let's think about the
world that we now live in.
And I'll give Silicon Valley as an example
because one could argue
that Silicon Valley
is maybe most indicative
of what 21st century,
what the 21st century
economy is going to look like
and what 21st century industry
is going to look like.
So, let's compare the Gilded Age,
to Silicon Valley,
home of folks like Google
and Facebook and Apple.
Well, Silicon Valley is
it about about capital
or is it about labor?
Well, the industries in Silicon Valley,
they're about creating technology,
they're about creating software.
Software, in particular,
requires very little capital.
You don't need large, a billion
dollar manufacturing plants.
You don't need a ton of land.
You literally can write
software in your bedroom.
You could do it in your closet.
That's how I started.
And so Silicon Valley is
really much more about labor.
That's not labor,
you know, when you think of labor
in the Gilded Age Industrial Revolution,
you're thinking about someone
just working on a factory line
or doing a repetitive
job over and over again.
While in Silicon Valley,
it's much more about highly skilled labor.
So let me write that in that blue color.
Highly,
highly skilled,
highly skilled labor.
And it's definitely the
case in Silicon Valley
that highly skilled labor
is viewed as a much,
a much stronger differentiator
for an organization
or an individual than capital.
In fact, the dynamics that
you're seeing more and more
in Silicon Valley is lots
and lots and lots of capital,
which is oftentimes
perceived as a commodity
pursuing a team of five people who've just
put something together
in the last few months,
and they're valuing it
at 10 million dollars
or 50 million dollars.
We see organizations like
Facebook and WhatsApp
getting multibillion
dollar valuations based on,
really the output of highly skilled labor.
Capital, there's some capital necessary.
You need office space, you need servers.
But it's not like the Gilded Age.
Most of the value is
in the part that's not
considered a commodity.
Office space is a commodity.
Servers are a commodity.
Highly skilled labor is not a commodity.
So, the question to ask yourself is:
Well, is this the case?
And is the case, will capital,
will R be able to stay larger than G?
And will more and more capital,
more income go to capital?
Or maybe does it go more and
more to highly skilled labor?
Now, the other question you need to,
or the other question that
may be going in your mind,
is well hey look, Silicon Valley
isn't just about software,
it's also about hardware.
One of the most highly
successful companies
in Silicon Valley is Apple Computers,
and they do write software,
but they're known for
their hardware products.
Their iPhone, the iPad, their computers.
What about that industry?
Isn't that capital intensive?
Well, let's just think about
how your iPhone or your
iPad gets developed.
It gets designed by Apple
in Cupertino, California,
and that's what they write on their boxes,
designed in California.
And then they send the designs over
to a bunch of firms.
This is just some of
Apple's suppliers here.
And these are incredibly
capital intensive industries.
But from Apple's point of view,
they view them more or less,
not all of them, some of them
have differentiated products,
they make a special type of
material or whatever else.
But many of them are viewed
as commodity manufacturers.
That, hey, you don't
give me the right price,
you're not giving me the right
few pennies per component,
I'm going to go to the other person
who can produce that same entity.
And then these folks put it all together,
manufacture the pieces,
send it back to Apple,
who'll package it,
and then market it.
And so, what is the high value aspect
of this supply chain right over here?
Well, it's clearly the
design and the marketing.
And if you don't believe that,
you should look at what portion
of the output of the income
generated by an iPhone,
what portion of it goes to Apple
versus what portion of it goes
to the suppliers right over here.
So, one way to think about it
is these are kind of closer
to the large scale capital
intensive manufacturing plants
of the Gilded Age.
Although, even here, R and
D plays a major component,
it did in the Gilded Age as well.
And once again, R and
D though, is a labor,
is a highly skilled labor.
It is less about, there's
capital definitely involved,
but when you look at
the real value created,
it's really on the highly
skilled labor part,
on the designing and the marketing side,
the creative aspects of it.
Now, just this, if you believe it,
and you should come to
your own judgements.
This by itself doesn't say that
we can't worry about inequality
because even this might say,
look, more and more income,
maybe it's not gonna go to capital,
it's gonna go to more and
more highly skilled labor.
And that's a small
subset, one could argue,
of the entire labor pool.
You have this highly skilled labor here.
And so you might have inequality,
not happening like it
happened in the Gilded Age,
where it's going to owners of capital,
but now it's going to, the
owners, I guess you could say,
of highly, highly skilled labor.
And so, that could drive inequality.
But this is where the
force of convergence,
that Piketty talks about, could play in.
And he seems a little bit skeptical
of its ability to overweight
the forces of capital accumulation.
But if we can have more people participate
in this more highly skilled labor,
then potentially this could
be a force of convergence.
It could balance things off,
and keep us from going into
some type of neo-Gilded Age.